[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع العيال اختيار استهلوها بابره
العنويه
[موسيقى]
وخلافات الغرب مع روسيا حول اوكرانيا
تهددها بالفشل
جده
الحرس الثوري ووزير الداخليه بسبب قمع
الاحتجاجات
الخدمه العسكريه للاجانب ويدرسوا سحب
جنسيه الفارين من التعبئه
[موسيقى]
قبيله انعقاد قمه العشرين كانت للرئيسين
الامريكيين والصينيه جوله من المفاوضات
المهمه جدا ليس على مستوى القمه فقط وانما
لاهميتها ابعاد اقتصاديه وسياسيه وربما
عسكريه على مستوى العالم الرئيسان عقد
اجتماعا مطولا استمر على مدى ثلاث ساعات
متواصله شدد خلاله الزعيمان على الحاجه
الى اداره الخلافات وتجنب النساء
امورك سباق
همم
الصين والولايات المتحده مره عبر 50 سنه
حافله بالاحداث التاريخ هو افضل كتاب لذلك
علينا ان نستفيد منه العلاقات بين الصين
والولايات المتحده حاليا تمر بحاله تدفعنا
للاهتمام بها ولا تصب في مصلحه بلدين
وشعبين وليست ما يتوقعه من المجتمع الدولي
لاننا قائدين لاكبر دولتين في العالم
علينا ان الصيغه طريق المناسبه للعلاقات
لايجاد الاتجاه الصحيح للعلاقه الثنائيه
مستقبلا وتطوير هذه العلاقات
معنى من واشنطن ريتشارد ويز كبير الباحثين
في معهد هات سون سد ريتشارد في ظل
التحديات السياسيه والاقتصاديه الداخليه
والخارجيه للرئيسين الامريكي والصيني هل
اداره الصراع وضبط خطوط الحمر لي يعني
خطوط الحمر للصراع بين الطرفين امم سهل
بهذه المرحله وبهذا التوقيت بالذات
العلاقات
لتصل الى مرحله
مواجهات بين الصين ولايه المتحده
لكنك
شاهدنا التوترات الاقتصاديه حول مساء
التجاريه والكتل الاقليميه والعمله
والملكيه الفكريه
كما شاهدنا التوترات الامنيه فيما يخص
تايوان والهند
والبحر الجنوب وشرق الصين كما شاهدنا
التوترات
الصين والولايات المتحده لديها حكومات
مختلفه ذات رؤى مختلفه وعلى الرغم من ان
رئيسين قد يتوافق فقط لان هذا لن يكون له
اثار كبير على المدى بعيد
واعتقد بان يجب ان تكون هنالك
لاداره يعلم واجهه بنفس الطريقه التي ادرت
فيها الولايات المتحده واتحاد السوفيتي
خلافات هما خلال الحرب البارده
للصراع الجيو سياسي الصراع السياسي بظل
الخوف من تاكل النظام العالمي الحالي بسبب
اتساع دوامه الصراع بين الافرقه هل هو
ممكن وعلى ماذا ممكن ان ينص
التحدي الاساسي
[موسيقى]
متاكدا همم
سيكون صعب جدا ادارتها امام المشاكل
الاخرى ربما
الشماليه
التعاون فيما يخصه تغير المناخي اما مع
تايوان فاعتقد بان الغالبيه
الولايات المتحده وليس اوكرانيا
يعني بالرغم من البوادر بوادر ال
الدبلوماسيه بين الطرفين هناك ملفات
اساسيه عالقه ملف تايوان هناك تشدد صيني
بهذا الموضوع ملف اشباه الموصلات ملفات
خارجيه عده منها الحرف في اوكرانيا وغيرها
كيف يمكن ايجاد يعني خط وسط بين الطرفين
بهذه الملفات التي تعتبر اساسيه بالخلاف
بين الطرفين
السابقه
في العام الماضي والتي هي في مجالات عديده
قال الولايات المتحده بامكانهما التنافس
وكل واحد يعرض نموذج هو على الدول وكل
دوله تختار ايهما يناسبها اكثر واكلاهما
يتنافسان على همم
وفي بعض المجالات يمكن يكون هنالك يتعاون
مثلا فيها افغانستان وغيرها ولكن يجب ان
نتجنب المواجهه بين البلدين لذلك اعتقد
بان هذا هو السبب الذي يتحدث فيه
عن همم
الحواجز التي تمنعه مثلا النزاعات همم
واعتقد ان هذه الفكره من
لحوار او الاتفاقات التي ترضع او تمنع
حصول المواجهه وان تتحول الى حرب
سن حدثنا
بناء ان على توجيه العاهل السعوديه الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز غدا ولي العهد الامير
محمد بن سلمان الى اندونيسيا لترقص وفد
المملكه المشارك في قمه قاد الدول مجموعه
العشرين التي ستعقد في مدينه باريس واوضح
الديوان الملكي السعوديان الامير محمد بن
سلمان عدد من الدول الاسيويه لبحث
العلاقات الثنائيه ومناقشه القضايا ذات
الاهتمام المشترك
طوال نحو 70 عاما ارتبطت السعوديه
واندونيسيا بعلاقات قويه ان من خلالها
اوجه التعاون في كافه الصعده ومنذ نشاه
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بينهما في العام
1948 ربط البلدين تاريخ طويل من العلاقات
حيث جمعتهما روابط دينيه واجتماعيه في
اندونيسيا تعد موطن اكبر عدد من السكان
المسلمين في العالم اما اقتصاديا فتجمعهما
عضويه مجموعه ال 20 فلكل البلدين اقتصاد
المتين يعد من بين الاقوى عالميا حيث ان
اقتصاد السعوديه هو الاعلى نموا في مجموعه
العشرين واندونيسيا واحده من افضل الاسواق
الناشئه اداء في العالم وفي مجال التعاون
التجاري تعد السعوديه الشركه التجاريه
الاول الاندونيسيا في الشرق الاوسط حيث
تجاوز حجم التبادل التجاري بين البلدين
خلال العام 2021 حاجزا 18 مليار ريال كما
تقدر نسبه مقارنه بالعام 2020 ب 37% فيما
بلغ التبادل التجاري خلال الخمس سنوات
الماضيه اكثر من 92 مليارات وعلى الصعيد
الانساني والاغاثي دعمت السعوديه عبر مركز
الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه
اندونيسيا خلال الفتره بين عام 2005 و22
بمشاريع باكثر من 72 مليون دولار في
قطاعات منها الصحه والتعليم والامن
الغذائي
[موسيقى]
مين بقى لي تنضم الينا مفاجات العربيه
ناديه البلبيسي ناديه
مشتركه لمواجهه التحديات بين الدول
المشاركين بهذه القمه كيف يمكن تطبيقه وما
هو جدول الاعمال
اهلا بيكي العيال طبعا القمه ستنطلق رسميا
غدا صباحا بحضور كل قاعده الدول مجموعه ال
20 المشاركه هناك الكثير من التحديات لهذه
القمه منها الامن الغذائي التغيير المناخي
اييي الضرائب وتخفيض الديون وهناك ايضا
شراكه ما بين هذه الدول والاتحاد الاوروبي
سيطلقها الرئيس ايضا تصل الى 600 مليار
دولار على مدى خمس سنوات يتم هناك استثمار
في البنيه التحتيه لهذه الدول هذه من
ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى هناك تحديات اخرى
مثلا الرئيس الروسي لم يحدث همم بوتي لم
يحضر الى هذه القمه كما تعرفين هناك من
يرى بان هناك ضغط امريكي همم على
اندونيسيا لم توجه الى دعوه او انه لم
يرغب بحضوره طبعا الوفد الامريكي قال بانه
كان يريد ايضا لرئيس جيلنسكي ان يخاطب قمه
العشرين عبر الفيديو لكن هذا لم يحدث عن
كل الاحوال اللقاء لاهم اليوم كما ذكرت في
بدايه النشره كان مع الرئيس الصيني وهذه
اول لقاء يجمع بايدن وجها لوجمع شيشبين
وهناك طبعا كما قال الرئيس المحاوله لفتح
قنوات الاتصال والابقاء عليها مفتوحه مع
بكين
وسيرسل الرئيس الامريكي وزير الخارجيه الى
لمتابعه الملفات التي تحدث عنها اليوم وهي
الحرب في اوكرانيا طبعا ووضع تايوان
وسياسه الولايات المتحده الابقاء على
الصين واحده بمعنى بانها لا ترغب ان يكون
هناك تغيير من اي من الاطراف سواء اكمن
طيب وان او حتى من الولايات المتحده لانه
زياره نانسي فلوسي اقلقت الصين في ذلك
الوقت عندما سئل شخصيه هذا الرئيس الذي
حصل على تفويض من الحزب الشيعي للمره
الثالثه للرئاسه قال بانه رئيس مباشر بان
اعرف عندما كنت نائب للرئيس لم يكن همم
ربما
ولم يكن اعرض عن انه مستعد لي ال يكون
هناك مسا- مساومات او يكون هناك ربما
تنازلات في بعض الملفات لكن هذا لقاء مهم
جدا لاهم اقتصادي اقتصاد دولتين في العالم
ناديه ايضا يعني زياره ولي العهد ومشاركته
في هذه القمه على راس وفد سعودي وزياره
عدد من الدول الاسيويه ما هي ابرز البنود
الموجوده على جدول الاعمى
طبعا السعوديه كاحد دول مجموعه ال20 لديها
الثقه الجيو السياسي والاقتصادي وبالتالي
تتطلب تربيتها مع اندونيسيا علاقه متينه
جدا على مستوى التجاري على مستوى السياسي
وعلى المستوى الدبلوماسي وبالتالي همم
سيكون هناك لقاءات للوفد السعودي مع
مجموعه قمه ال 20 سيكون هناك حديث عن رؤيه
الامير 20 30 عن تطبيق ل همم المشاريع
التي تتعلق بالبيئه بالدرجه الاولى همم
السعوديه بقياده الامير محمد بن سلمان هي
في دور الرياده راينا في طبعا قمه شرم
الشيخ وايضا هنا في مجموعه دول العشرين
هذه القمه ستنطلق غدا في همم طبعا بمشاركه
كل قاده هذه الدول وسيكون هناك غذاء عمل
لبحث وتقسيم الى اللجان لبحث كل القضايا
التي ذكرته على قائمه هذه القمه همم الامن
الغذائي طبعا بالدرجه الاولى خصوصا بعد
رائحه كورونا
الازمه همم مع اوكرانيا وروسيا بالنسبه
لتصدير الحبوب والى اخره وايضا كما تعرفين
القضايا الاخرى المتعلقه بالبنيه التحتيه
همم
التصحر
وموضوع التغيير المناخي التي ستضغى بدرجه
كبيره على هذه القمه شكرا لك ناديه
البلبيسي مفردات العربيه حدثتنا من باريس
اذا تبدا قمه مجموعه ال 20 في جزيره بالي
الاندونيسيه يوم الغد وبعد غد وابرز ملامح
هذه القمه هو غياب الرئيس الروسي فلاتيني
منذ تسعه اشهر بظلالها على اعمالها فالحرب
تسببت بالعديد من الازمات العالميه وخاصه
على صعيد امدادات الطاقه والغذاء والمواد
الاوليه حيث ادت الحرب التي اندلعت شررتها
مع الغزو الروسيه لاوكرانيا في شباط
الماضي الى ارتفاعا حاد في معدلات التضخم
حول العالم وتبخر الامال بالتعافي
الاقتصادي من تبعات رائحه كورونا فما هي
مجموعه ال 20 سنه
[موسيقى]
تتناول قمه العشرين مجموعه من القضايا في
لقاءاتها الدوليه منها نمو الاقتصاد
العالميه والتجاره الدوليه وتنظيم اسواق
المال العالميه فالهدف الاساسي للمجموعه
هو تقويه النظام المالي العالمي وتعزيز
اليات الرقابه عليها لمنع تكرار الازمه
العالميه الماليه التي شهدها العالم عام
2008 كما تهدف المجموعه الى عدم ترك اي
قطاع من السوق الماليه العالميه بعيدا عن
الرقابه ومحاربه التهرب الضريبي وتفادي
المنافسه عن طريق تخفيض الضرائب كما تسعى
قمه العشرين الى التركيز على تحقيق نمو
المستدامه مستمر واقتصاد متوازن وخلق مزيد
من الوظائف للاقتصاد العالمي منذ قمه
واشنطن التي عقدت عام 2008 اصبحت التجاره
العالميه احد اهم البنود على جدول اعمال
المجموعه بسبب العلاقه الوثيقه بين حريه
التجاره العالميه والحد من البطاله
تغير المناخ سياسات التنميه اسواق العمل
وقوانينها نشر التقنيه الهجره وقضيه
اللجوء ومحاربه الارهاب قضايا تدخل ايضا
في جدول اعمال قمه العشرين
[موسيقى]
يبلغ انت مجموعه ال 20 80% من اجماليه
الانتاج العالمي فيما تبلغ حصتها من حجم
التجاره العالميه 75% ويبلغ عدد سكان دول
مجموعه العشرين ثلثي سكان الكره الارضيه
طبعا مشاهدينا تضم المجموعه عددا من
المنظمات والهيئات الدوليه التي تحضر
القمه كما اسلفنا منها صندوق النقد الدولي
والبنك الدولي ومنظمه التجاره الدوليه
بالاضافه الى مجلس الاستقرار المالي
منظمه التنميه والتعاون الاقتصادي ومنظمه
العمل الدوليه والامم المتحده ويحق لرؤساء
هذه الدول المشاركه في القمه دعوه زعماء
من خارج المجموعه طبعا مجموعه ال 20 ليست
منظمه دوليه لكنها اشبه بمنتدى غير رسميه
وبالتالي المجموعه لا تتخذ قرارات ملزمه
قانونيه للدول الاعضاء في المجموعه كما لا
تملك المجموعه سكرتاريه دائمه او موظفين
ثابتين ومنذ الازمه الماليه العالميه عام
2008 باتت القمه سنويه ويحضرها وزراء
الماليه ومدير البنوك المركزيه في الدول
الاعضاء في هذه المجموعه
[موسيقى]
التاسعه مستمره فيها بعد قليل
التجنيد كابوس يلاحق الشباب الروسي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلن الاتحاد الاوروبي
فرض عقوبات اضافيه على تسعه وعشرين فردا
وثلاثه كيانات في ايران على خلفيه قمع
الاحتجاجات واوضح الاتحاد الاوروبي ان
العقوبات شامله وزير الداخليه الايرانيه
والتلفزيون رسمي وكذلك قائد القوات البريه
الايرانيه وقاده في الحرس الثوري
ايران تختلق داخليا وخارجيا تظاهرات
الحراك ضد النظام لا تهدا بينما العزله
تحكم بمفاصل النظام الايراني لقلعه المميت
للتظاهرات التي فجرها غضبا مقتل مهس اميلي
المحتاجين هتافا ضد المرشد تهاجم الشرطه
المتظاهرين وتعتقل منهم المئات السلطات
وجهه الاتهام بقضايا ملفقه يصل بعضها لحكم
الاعدام لنحو 800 متضاهر والجريمه
الاحتجاج ضد النظام
النظام الذي لا ينفقه يهاجمه الاخر الدول
الغربيه لاعلان تضامنها ووقوفها الى جانب
المحتجين
بفرد عقوبات الاوروبيه على طهران لقمعها
الاحتياجات الى تجديد الرئيس الفرنسي ووصف
ما يحدث في ايران للمره الثانيه بانها
ثوره مواصلا تاكيده ان العقوبات المفروضه
على النظام يجب ان لا يتاثر بها الشعب
الايراني فيما يواصل الاتحاد الاوروبي فرض
عقوبات اضافيه ضد المسؤولين طمع
الاحتجاجات حيث تشمل الحزمه الجديده واح
31 تصنيفا لانتهاكات حقوق الانسان تستهدف
الافراد والكيانات بفرض حظر على الاصول
وتجميد السفر
مد التظاهرات مستمره وبتكتيكات مختلفه وسط
تضامن الدولي غير مسبوق في ما يجد النظام
الايراني نفسه في مازق مواجهه داخليه
واخرى خارجيه
100 فنان ايراني الاعتقال او المنع من
مغادره البلاد وفقا دار السينما الايرانيه
التي اعادت قائمه ب 100 سينمائيه وفنان
موسيقي ومسرحي تم اعتقالهم او منعه من
مغادره البلاد في الاشهر القليله الماضيه
وكتبت صحيفه شرق ان لجنه الحمايه
القانونيه والقضائيه عن السينمائيين اعلنت
ايضا انه خلال هذه المده تم منع اشهر
الممثلين والمخرجين من العمل كما تم انهاء
عقود عدد منهم ورفض اعضاء هذه اللجنه نشر
اسماء الاشخاص حمايه لحقوق المعتقلين
لكنها صحيفه شرق قالت ان مخرج الافلام
الوثائقيهون رياح من بين الفنانين
المعتقلين
من لندن ينضم الينا يوسف عزيزي عضو اتحاد
الكتاب الايرانيين استاذ يوسف ما يتعرض له
السينمائيين والفنانين الايرانيين بدا قبل
هذه الحركه الاحتجاجيه منذ فتره ومازال
عدد منهم محتجزين حتى الساعه يعني امم
الحمل حمله النظام الايراني لقمع النموذج
الذي اليوم يعني يقود عدد من التظاهرات
تاتي بنتيجه عكسيه لماذا لم يوقفها بعد
كم الكرام
النظام
الاول لقيامه ثوره في ايران قبل 43 سنه ان
اييه يعني يسيطر على كل
وجوه الفن
وشك المؤسسات
لهذا العام مثل المؤسسات سوره
لكن
ان غلب السعر السعر على الساحر بعد هذه
السنوات بعد ان في الواقع هؤلاء الفنانين
والسينمائيين همم يعني ادركوا ان هذا
النظام هو يقتل ابناء شعبه شعبهم يقتل
النساء
حتى القصه فلهذا همم في الواقع حتى هذه
مؤسسه الصوره اللي هو اساسها للفن الديني
اصبحت جامعه للتظاهر والاحتجاج
هؤلاء الناس يعني الفنانين والكتاب
والصحفيين هم هم من الشعب وهم يعني يدركون
ويشعرون بالام الشعر وما يعانيه من مشاكل
اقتصاديه
رقابه
مع صناع الفن والقوه الناعمه الايرانيه
لبث الخوف داخل المجتمع الايراني اليس هو
دليل جديد على ضعف هذا النظام ومهنه من
الداخل
نعم هذا النظام بما انه عاجز
وضعيف عن مواجهه الاحتجاجات والمظاهرات
التي ستدخل بعد يومين شهر ثالث يعني
خسرا كل كل القطاعات يعني
ليس فقط الفنانين ايضا الرياضيين وهو الان
قلق ماذا يفعل في قطر في الدوحه في في في
المباريات يعني كاس العالم لكره القدم
هناك ستكون ستكون هدافين ضده
يعني النظام الذي يعني بطبيعه
معتقداته او عقيداته ينشر الموت في
المنطقه من الطبيعي ان يكره من يصنع
الحياه عبر الفن هذا الصراع بين هذين ان
نموذجين كيف يمكن ان يكمل بالفتره المقبله
كما ذكرتهم في الواقع الفنانين والكتاب هم
صناع الحياه هم يعني طموحهم لاجل تجديد
الحياه وهو اييه يعني يروج للموت منذ
اليوم الاول يعني بدا بالاعدامات العشرات
والمئات من السجناء السياسيين وغيرهم
فلهذا الان هذه
المواجهه مستعده في الواقع بين جبهه الشعب
وممثلين من همم من الرياضيين والفنانين
وكتاب وصفيين والنظام الذي اصبح بمفرده
وكما ذكرته ايضا مضغوط عليه على الدوليه
الان الاتحاد الاوروبي اللي كان يعود عليه
همم ايران كان يعود عليها الان هي تفرض
عقوبات على هذا النظام فلهذا هو الان في
في الواقع في طريق جود لا يعرف كم كيف
يخرج من هذه الازمه شكرا لك استاذ يوسف
عزيزي عضو اتحاد الكتاب الايرانيين على
هذه المدخره
[موسيقى]
للمره الاولى منذ ثمانيه اشهر تمكن عمال
الاغاثه من الدخول الى خرسان محملينا
بالمساعدات الانسانيه الامم المتحده سلمت
اليوم امدادات تكفي لمساعده اكثر من سته
الاف مدني بعد ثلاثه ايام من السعاده
القوات الاوكرانيه للسيطره على المدينه
وشامله القافله الانسانيه الطعام والماء
ومستلزمات النظافه والادوات المنزليه
الضروريه بما فيها الاغطيه الحراريه
والمصابيح الشمسيه المراكز الصحيه في
المدينه ستتلقى ايضا ادويه لعلاج اكثر من
1000 مريض خلال الاشهر المقبله الجهات
الاخرانيه المختصه تعمل الى جانبه ازاله
الالغام على اعاده امدادات الغاز
والاتصالات ويكافح سكان خرسون طبعا الذين
يصل عددهم حاليا ل 80,000 شخص لتلبيه
احتياجاتهم الاساسيه في ظل نقص حاد في
المياه هو المواد الغذائيه وبالتامن مع
توزيع المساعدات حتى حاكم مدينه خ السكان
على تجنب الاماكن المزدحمه محذرا من
تفجيرات محتمله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
سوبر ستار سوبر
عنوانين اساسيين لتصريحات الرئيس
الاوكراني و روايات السكان كذلك بعد ايام
على السعاده
وسكان هذه المنطقه اتهم الجنود الروس
بارتكاب الفضاء فيها كما كل منطقه اخرى او
كل منطقه اخرى دخلوها الروس وفقا تعبيرها
المحقق كونان وثقوا اكثر من 400 جريمه حب
بعد العثور على مقابر جماعيه تحوي مئات
الجثث المدنيين وبحسب ما نقلته صحيفه
الواشنطن بوست فانا اظهار سكان لاي علامه
على الانتمائهم لاوكرانيا كانت كفيله
بتلقيهم رصاصه او التعرض للتعذيب وهذا ما
دفعهم الى طمر اعلامهم او اي علامات تحوي
اللونين الاصفر والازرق في منازلهم التي
تعرضت للتفتيش الدائم والنهب بحسب الصحيفه
[موسيقى]
في ذات السياق وبعد ايامنا على انسحاب
القوات الروسيه من مدينه خيرسون بدات هذه
القوات باخلاء مدينه نوفا كخوفكا ثاني
اكبر مدينه في منطقه خرسون جنوبيه
اوكرانيا وذلك ضمن اجراءاتها لتعزيز خط
الدفاع على طول الضفه اليسرى نهر النيبرو
التي انسحبت القواتها اليها حيث تم فرد
منطقه اخلاء اجباريه على طول 10 اميال
جنوب نهر النيبرو قبل هجوم اوكرانين متوقع
وفقا مسؤولينا رؤوس واكد تقارير اعلاميه
روسيه بدا بناء هياكل وتحصينات عسكريه في
هذه المنطقه لافته الا ان الجيش الروسي ده
الاف الاشخاص في شهرين سبتمبر واكتوبر
لحفل خنادق على طول نهر النيبرو علما بان
مدينه نوفا كخوفكا تقعوا على بعد حوالي 56
كم من مدينه خرسون ويقدر عدد سكانها قبل
الحرب بخمسه واربعين الف نسمه
نظام التجنيد العسكري كابوس متواصل يلاحق
الشباب الروس رغم اعلان الرئيس الروسي
ووزير الدفاع الانتهاء من تعبئه نحو
300,000 جندي جديد
فالعديد من الروس الذين تنطبق عليهم
مواصفات المقاتل اي سنه واللياقه الجسديه
المطلوبه لا يزالون مختبئين وسط مخاوف من
ارسالهم للقتال وما قالوا انه الموت في
حرب فاشله الهاربون غير اماكن سكنهام
وبعضهم متى يقيم في خيم بالغابات وفق
واشنطن بوست فيما الاختارات متراكمه على
ابواب منازلهم خوفا من التعرض لكمائنا
والاضطرار لتسلم استدعاءاتنا والتوقيع
عليها كما حصل مع اقربائهم
لا سيما ان الاعلان عن انتهاء التعبئه لم
يترافق مع مرسوم قانون رسميا ينهي حمله
التجنيد الاجباريه
التجنيد جزء من حمله اجراءات شنتها روسيا
منذ بدا عمليتها في اوكرانيا واخرها
اعتزام الرئيس الروسي تجريد مواطنين من
جوازات سفرهم الروسيه في حال انتقادهم
للحربه صحف غربيه اكدت اقتراح فتن تغييرات
على مشروع قانون يستهدف المواطنين غير
الموجودين في روسيا والذين حصلوا على
جوازات السفر الروسيه اثناء الحرب مضيفه
ان المقترحه تمريره
وهنا المقصود الاوكرانيون الذين اجبروا او
لم يكن لديهم خيار لتغيير جنسيتها بسبب
التهديدات الروسيه بعد دخول مدنها وفقه
صحيفه كيف
معنى مكياج الاكاديميه والبحث السياسي
الدكتور ميكولا بستون استاذ استاذ دكتور
ميكولا سابدا من موضوع التفاوض الروسي
الاوكراني بما انه الحدث اليوم بالساعات
الماضيه هناك يعني اتفاق او تفاوض عنوانه
الاساسي التفاوض بين الجانب الامريكي
والروسي ضمن صفقه كبيره تشمل كل الملفات
بين الطرفين همم مع تنازلات من جانب اكياس
ما هي التنازلات التي يمكن الاكياف
تقديمها بعد كل هذه الاشهر من الخساره
الداخليه
مساء الخير
ربنا مشاركه اوكرانيا في المفاوضات معروس
بين امريكا وبين روسيا انا لا اعرف بالضبط
على اي مستوى تجري هذه هي المفاوضات
الروسي لا يشارك في ااا
مرسيدس
الخارجيه روسيه الان في المستشفى
لمشاركه
همم
قال همم
ان الجانب الروسي همم على استيراد في هذه
المفاوضات معنويه ونفسيا همم بمعنى ان ههه
موضوع المفاوضات لا يمكن ان يكون تنازل
عن همم هذا همم
يعني هذا الامر لا يناقش همم موضوع
المفاوضات همم من وجهه نظر الجانب
الاوكراني قد يكون شروط انسحاب القوات
الروسيه من الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وهمم التعويضات همم
يعني هناك شروط اوكرانيه خمسه جار الحديث
عنها بالساعات الماضيه ولكن كان اللافت
تراجع الرئيس اذال سكي عن شرط كان قد خطه
بالوثيقه التي يعني اصدرها بعد ضم المناطق
وهو عدم الذهاب الى تفاوض مع روسيا بظل
وجود الرئيس الروسي بوتر هل هناك ضغط
امريكي على كياف بهذه المفاوضات
واوروبا ايضا
امر ممكن ربما
على ما يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال
الروسيه من العراق
على زياده عدد اللاجئين على الضغوطات
الاقتصاديه الداخليه والمعيشيه التي
تواجهها اوروبا على ابواب الشتاء كيف يمكن
ان ينعكس هذا الضغط ايضا على مطالبك
ااا خد الضغط
[موسيقى]
من التصريحات الزعماء الاوروبيين قالوا
نظامهم ان المفاوضات ستكون الذي
فقدنا الاتصال مجددا شكرا لك يا دكتور
حدثنا من ثياب الاكاديمي والباحث السياسي
عن موضوع المفاوضات الاوكرانيه الروسيه
اعلنت الحكومه الالمانيه انها بصدد تامين
فرع عن سابق لمجموعه الطاقه الروسيه
العملاقه جاست بروم معتبره الخطوه ضروريه
في ضوئي اهميه الشركه بالنسبه لامدادات
الطاقه في البلاد ومؤسسه تامين الطاقه
لاوروبا المعروفه اختصارا باسم سفي كانت
تحمل سابقا اسم جاستروم جورمانيا وهي شبكه
تشغيل وتسيطر بشكل غير مباشره على اكبر
منشاه لتخزين الغاز في بلده في شمالي غرب
المانيا
تتابعونا في التاسعه ولكن بعد قليل
اتفاق فرنسي بريطاني لتشديد الرقابه على
بحر الماش
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اشار وزير الدفاع اليمني
في تصريحات للعربيه الى ان التحالف العربي
بقياده السعوديه قدم الكثير من الاسلحه
والمال والارواح لدعم الجيش والشرعيه
اليمنيه مؤكدا ان اذا لم تهزم مليشيات
الحوثي عسكريا ستظل خطرا على اليمن
لا يعني لا استطيع ان اقدم شكر او ثناء
يثيب بحق الدول
التحالف العربي مثلا في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه دوله الامارات العربيه المتحده
فقد قدموا الكثير من الاسلحه والمال بل
قدموا دماؤهم وارواحهم في
انتصارهم هذه القضيه وقفه الى جانبنا في
كل الاتجاهات وفي كل اماكن
ممتاز جدا ولكن انا ننتظر يعني المزيد
خلال الفتره القادمه بحيث همم
يجب ان يتحقق النصر مهما كانت الصعوبه
اليوم الاول نحن نعقد معهم الاتفاق
الاتفاق منذ ان كانوا في مران التاخر
الاتفاق وما ان يقف حبر مزاد القالب الذي
وقعت فيه الاتفاق الا وتنقذ كل هذه
الاتفاقيات العود وبالتالي ننتظر ان هذه
المليشيات اذا لم ترجع وتلزم وتعود الى
همم مكانها الطبيعي ستظل خطر على همم
يمن وتظهر خطر على المنطقه برمتها بل على
طرق الملاحه العالميه كلها
رئيس المجلس الاعلى للدوله في ليبيا خالد
المشرق
وصفح الحكومه الملشاويه وانها تسعى
للسيطره على البلاد عبر فرض الراي بالقوه
وقفنا من هذه الحكومه هيكون واضح بانها
حكومه من اسيويه تريد السيطره بالقوه وفرض
رايها بالقوه
تصريحات المشرجات بعدما منعت قوه عسكريه
تابعه لحكومه الوحده الوطنيه برئاسه عبد
الحميد دبابه اعضاء المجلس الاعلى للدوله
من الاجتماع في طرابلس وقالت مصادر
العربيه ان الجلسه كان من المفترض ان
تستعرض تقرير لجنه اختيار المناصب
السياديه واليه توحيد السلطه التنفيذيه
[موسيقى]
وقعت فرنسا وبريطانيا اتفاقا جديده يهدف
الى وقفه عبور المهاجرين بحر المانش الى
انجلترا على متن قوارب صغيره ومعالجه
اسباب هذا الجذريه الاتفاق مدته عمان
ويلزم بريطانيا بدفع مبلغ قدره 74 مليون
دولار لفرنسا عمي
20223 على ان تزيد السلطات الفرنسيه عدد
عناصر قواتها الامنيه الذين يسيرون دوريات
على شواطئ فرنسا الشماليه بنسبه 40% وزاره
الدفاع البريطانيه اعلنت عن عبور اكثر من
40 الف مهاجر قناه الماتش الى بريطانيا
العام الحالي معظمهم من الالبان
والايرانيين والافغان واوضحت كذلك ان
العدد في الزياده الكبير مقارنه بالعام
الماضي الذي سجل نحو 29,000 في ما لم
يتجاوز العدد
800,500 قبل عامين و300 فقط عام وثمانيه
عشر
[موسيقى]
من اعلان تحقيق التقدم من خلال المحادثات
مع الرئيس الفرنسي امن والمكرون في قمه
المناخ وزيره الداخليه
البريطاما توقع مع نظيرها الفرنسي اتفاقا
لزياده الدوريات على الشواطئ الفرنسيه
بنسبه 40% بهدف منع المهاجرين من عبور
القناه الانجليزيه بموجب هذه الصفقه
الجديده سترفع الحكومه البريطانيه انفقها
على الدوريات ومعيدات المراقبه الى 63
مليون جنيه
الاشخاص الذين يعبرون القناه بشكل كبير
لقد كان رئيس الوزراء واضحا تماما وكنت
واضحه ايضا ان الهجره غير المشروعه لاسيما
في الاعداد التي رايناها مؤخرا غير مقبوله
تماما وهذا هو سبب وجودي في باريس اليوم
للتوقيع على اتفاقيه التعاون الجديده مع
الفرنسيين لمعالجه هذه المشكله
سناك بدا متفائلا بالاتفاق خصوصا انه يسمح
للمره الاولى باستضافه فرنسا ضباط شرطه
بريطانيين كمراقبين للمساعده في تنسيق
وتبادل المعلومات حول شبكات تهريب البشر
معا الناس اجراء واحد لا يستطيع ان يحل
المشكله بشكل سحريه لا نستطيع فعل ذلك
فجاه
انتقادات عديده وجهت للاتفاق فورا الاعلان
عنه فمنظمه امن ستي اعتبرت ان الاتفاق
سيؤدي الى مزيد من الرحلات الخطيره بسبب
رفض بريطانيا القبول بحصتها من طالب
اللجوء فيما وصف حزب العمال المعارض
الاتفاق بانه ضعيف ومتاخر في ان
مع توقيع الاتفاق الجديد مع فرنسا ووسط
تشديد الحكومه البريطانيه على عدم وجود
اجراء واحد لسيطره على الهجره غير
القانونيه لا يبدو ان مهمه سوناك وبرغم من
ستكون سهله هذا ما يقوله المعارضون على
الاقل خصوصا مع وصول 40 الف مهاجر ان هذا
العام مصطفى زارو العربيه لندن
من باريس ومصطفى زاروا من لندن سابدا معك
حسين يعني اتفاق توزيع اعباء المهاجرين
غير الشرعيين بين كل من بريطانيا وفرنسا
كيف تقراه الاوساط الفرنسيه وكيف يعني
سيكون التطبيق
هناك هاجس مشترك ربما في فرنسا وبريطانيا
ليال وهو مزايده قوى اقصى اليمين واليمين
المتطرف على الحكومه في موضوع المهاجرين
برز ذلك من خلال الازمه التي نشات قبل
ايام بين ايطاليا وفرنسا بسببي رفض الاولى
لاستقبال سفينه مهاجرين اطره فرنسا لاحقا
لاستقبالها في طولان جنوب البلاد والامر
نفسه يتكرر بعد توقيع الاتفاق بين
بريطانيا وفرنسا تذكير فقط بان من وقعت
الاتفاق مع وزير الداخليه الفرنسي
عن الجانب البريطاني هي السؤال لا برايفر
مان وهي ايضا من اقصى اليمين المحافظ في
بريطانيا طبعا هذا الاتفاق ينص كما ذكرت
في مقدمه الخبر على دفع بريطانيا مبلغا
ماليا لفرنسا هو 72 مليون يورو مقابل
القيام فرنسا بزياده حجم القوى الامنيه
المنتشره عند الحدود البحريه بين البلدين
تحديدا في كليه شمال فرنسا بالاضافه الى
ذلك يعني تقوم فرنسا بزياده بواقع 40% اي
ان 350 عنصر امن فرنسي سيضافون الى حواله
850 منتشرين حاليا في منطقه كليه شمال
البلاد كما ان الاتفاق الذي وقعه جيرارد
عن الجانب الفرنسي وسويلا درايفر بريطانيا
نصف على تكثيف نشر المراقبه كاميرات
المراقبه وكلاب بوليسيه عند النقاط
البحريه الرئيسيه بين البلدين بالاضافه
الى استخدام وسائل تقنيه
وبشريه اضافيه استخدام المسيارات مثلا على
مدارس ساعه فوق شمال فرنسا لضماني عدم
عبور مهاجرين غير شرعيين نحو بريطانيا
ياتي ذلك بعد عام من المفاوضات بين
البلدين اثراك كارثه غرق في 27 مهاجر خير
شرعي في بحر الماش في الرابع والعشرين من
نوفمبر الماضي هذا ما ادى الى تكثيف
المفاوضات التي استمرت عاما وصولا الى هذا
الاتفاق اليوم بين بريطانيا وفرنسا الليل
بعد سنوات من اذا صح التعبير السجلات
المشتركه بين كل من فرنسا وبريطانيا حول
موضوع
المهاجرين ياتي اليوم هذا الاتفاق
بعهد سوناك كيف تقراه الاوساط الداخليه
البريطانيه خصوصا ايضا ان موضوع المهاجرين
هو موضوع سيجال سياسي بالدارجه الاولى
حقيقه يعني كل السياسيين يقولون بان هذه
الاتفاقيه هي في الاتجاه الصحيح لكن لن
تكون كافيه خصوصا وان كانت هناك اتفاقيات
منذ 2015 هذا الاتفاق هو الثامن تقريبا
بريطانيا دفعت ما لا يقل عن 232 مليون
جنيه استرني ودعت النائب المحافظه همم
الف ان في نائب عن منطقه دوبر التي عاده
ما تستقبل المهاجرين القديمين من الشواطئ
الفرنسيه دعت الحكومه ان ان ان ان تعمل
المزيد وليس نفس الاتفاقيه لانها لن تكون
فعاله ويجب ويجب يعني همم التصدي منبع ال-
ال- يعني الذين ينظمون هذه الرحلات
الرحلات الموت من شواطئ الفرنسيه على عكس
همم ما ما ما جرى من قال وبالتالي تقول
بانه يجب على الوكاله الوطنيه لمكافحه
الجريمه ان لها ايضا دور في محاربه همم
مهربي البشر بالتالي هناك انتقادات وهناك
ربما رضا يعني بسيط من قبل حزب المحافظين
حتى ان الحكومه لم لم تناكد بان هذه
الاتفاقيه ستوقف توافد المهاجرين بشكل غير
شهر وبالتالي همم يقولون بان يريدون ان
يقلص العدد اكثر من 40,000 مهاجر وصلوا
الى شواطئ البريطانيه قادمين من الشواطئ
الفرنسيه واا يعني ان كان همم يعني سيتم
رصد ما لا يقل عن 80% من هذه المحاولات
الخطيره ستكون الحكومه راضيه عن همم عمل
الفرنسيين وان كان هناك مراقبون همم
بريطانيون لن تكون لهم صلاحيات تشغيليه
فيما يتعلق ما يجري على الاراضي الفرنسيه
حسين ساعود اليك ازمه العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين كل من ايطاليا وفرنسا على
خلفيات المهاجرين ايضا كيف يمكن ان تحل هل
من حوار جديد بين الطرفين وماذا حل
بالمهاجرين الذين تم استقبالهم مؤقتا على
ما اعتقد به ميناء
بالنسبه للشق الاول من سؤالك ليال الدليل
على ان الازمه لم تحل بين البلدين هو ان
الاتصال الهاتفي الذي جرى اليوم بين
الجانبين الايطالي والفرنسي لم يحصل بين
الرئيس ايمانويل ماكرون ورئيسه وزراء
ايطاليا جورجيا ميلوني كما يفترضا يحصل
لانها رئيسه السلطه التنفيذيه في ايطاليا
تعرفين ان الرئيس في ايطاليا هو يعني له
منصب فخري الاتصال حصل اليوم بين نكرون
والرئيس الايطالي ومنصبه فخري وليس منصبا
تنفيذيا كما هو منصب رئيس الوزراء وصدر
بعد هذا الاتصال بيان مشترك فرنسي ايطالي
جاء فيها انه من الضروري توفير كل الشروط
اللي ضمان لتعاون كامل بين البلدين في
جميع الميادين سواء كان ذلك على المستوى
الثنائي بين ايطاليا وفرنسا او على
المستوى الاوروبي في ذلك تلميح الى ان
التعاون الكامل ليس موجوده بالنسبه لمصير
المهاجرين الذين وصلوا الى هنا
70 من بين المئتين 2034 مهاجرا
ستتوزعهم 11 دوله اوروبيه اما الباقون
فسيبقون في فرنسا وستدرس طلبات لجوؤهم هذه
الدول 11 التي ستستقبلهم هي ايرلندا
وفنلندا والمانيا والوكسمبور و النرويج
وبلغاريا
شبكات تهريب البشر هل هي ممكن مع هذه
الجهود المشتركه الفرنسيه البريطانيه
يعني
العمل مع فرنسا يعني يعود الى اكثر من سبع
سنوات ولكن هذا العمل ليس فعالا لوقف
توافد همم المهاجرين بشكل غير قانوني لكن
هناك مطالب من قبل منظمات حقوق الانسان
وايضا منظمات معنيه باللجوء بان تنشا
المملكه المتحده ممرات وطرق امنه وقانونيه
لطلب اولئك لدينا يريدون المجيء الى
المملكه المتحده وبالتالي هذا لم ترضخ الي
حتى الان الحكومه وبانتظارنا همم يمكن ان
ان ان تعمل بخصوص هذه المطالب وان لم تكون
هذه الخطه همم الجديده فعاله في وقف وصول
المهاجرين بطرق غير شرعيه شكرا لكم
مراسيلي العربيه حسين القنيبر من باريس
ومصطفى زاروا من لندن على هذه الرسائل
في ملف المهاجرين ايضا ولكن في ليبيا هذه
المره جرى اعتراض حوالي 100000 شخص منذ
توقيع اتفاق الهجره بين الاتحاد الاوروبي
وطرابلس وفقا المنظمات حقوقيه اتفاق يهدده
العنف الذي تمارسهم لشيات مسلحه على
المهاجرين ومراكز الاعتقال في ليبيا
على كف عفريت مخاطر جمه يواجهها المهاجرون
الذين تهددهم اسلحه ميليشيه تتقمص دور حفر
السواحل
المنظمه الانسانيه امانه
للذخيره الحيه ضد قوارب لمهاجرين في اعالي
البحار الانتقادات تشير ايضا الى نقص
المسؤوليه والشفافيه بشان متلقيا من حيث
ليبيا
التطورات تاتي في ما يوضع عدد كبير من
الاشخاص الذين جرع اعتراضيهم في البحر في
مراكز ليبيه تم تشبيهها بمراكز اعتقال
منظمه حقوقيه دوليه اكدت ان المهاجرين في
ليبيا يتعرضون للتعذيب كما انهم ضحايا
للعنف الجنسي والعبوديه من قبل عناصر
المليشيات المسلحه لكن السلطات الليبيه
تنفيذ ذلك
مدافعون عن حقوق الانسان يؤكدونا ان سد
المهاجرين من مناطق البحث والانقاذ
الاوروبيه باتجاه ليبيا يعتبر بموجب قانون
الاتحاد الاوروبي غير قانوني اذا كانت
الدول الاوروبيه متواطئه انتقادات لم تقدم
الحكومه الايطاليه ردودا عن اسئله بشانها
خاصه مع صعود اليمنيه
مجلس اوروبا اكد من جهته ان عرقله انشطه
الانقاذ التي تقوم بها المنظمات غير
الحكوميه والفشل في تخصيص موانئ امنه
وقريبه لانزال الذين يتم انقاذهم في البحر
في هذه الحاله في ايطاليا
تكتيكات تهدف الى فتح المجاري امام عمليات
اعتراض من قبل خفر سواحل الليبي على الرغم
من الادله القاطعه على الانتهاكات الجسيمه
لحقوق الانسان بلال الوجدان العربيه
ختام التاسعه مع العناوين
امريكيه صينيه
الغرب مع روسيا حول اوكرانيا تهددها
بالفشل
[موسيقى]
المصريه
يوقعوا مرسوما يسمحوا باداء الخدمه
العسكريه للاجانب ويدرس سحب جنسيه الفارين
من التعبئه
مشاهدينا التاسعه انتهت لكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره